I don't want to talk about politics
tonight
[Music]
one side is very pro-gun the other side
is very anti-gun I don't think they
thought through that strategy
women sports still way too competitive
for me so what I think I'm gonna start
doing is identifying as a kid start
playing peewee football
and I think gluten is the Donald Trump
of the food World a lot of people say
they're intolerant
most of those people go home and crave
it don't they Joe Biden died two years
ago did y'all ever see the movie Weekend
at Bernie's push him out on stage uh
time to give a speech Joe
I remember the my one of my best friends
on the planet he directed this special
his name's Brent Pella he and I were in
San Diego doing shows for a weekend uh
late last year and I said bro I don't
I'm ready to do a special I want to I
don't think I can obviously the the
typical places Netflix is in Amazon's
given the nature of the content I'm
doing on stage they're not going to have
it it's just way removed from the
mainstream narrative I couldn't even
release it on YouTube for free if I
wanted to that would get my channel
deleted like that
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
comedian whose new stand-up special
please censor this is out now
exclusively on locals JP Sears I don't
know how this hasn't happened before but
finally welcome to the Reuben report
right out well thank you for having me
Dave and it's been a pleasure to meet
you in person a couple times and I'm
glad to be invited to the Sacred Garden
of that report I honestly don't know how
this hasn't happened before we've bumped
into each other many times over the
years at a lot of libertarian events a
lot of places where people are carrying
American flags like right behind you
back there uh I obviously I want to get
into the special and talk comedy and all
that stuff but I guess first uh people
don't associate comedians with freedom
anymore which is a very bizarre thing uh
were you always kind of libertarian-ish
Freedom focused blah blah blah or was it
a bit of a pushback against all the
woken sanity over the last couple years
yeah it's it I wasn't always this way it
it's it's been a bit of a pushback I
mean look just like so many other people
and I'll admit it I was living in a
bubble of ignorance and entitlement just
like okay well this is America like why
you don't need to worry about Freedom
like we can take it for granted
uh surprise uh it turns out that's not
the case and I I don't like that I lived
in the bubble of ignorance but I did
until our freedom started getting taken
away and you just see a few study
patterns of History you see where it
could go if we allow it so that that
helped me realize
Freedom's my number one value like
everything great in life depends on
freedom and my my child being able to
have a great life and his children one
day they need Freedom so you know I I
used to
just never be in the politics couldn't
even tell you what the difference
between a Democrat and Republican was
but looking back I could see like yeah I
leaned liberal uh and it was kind of
cool but not anymore
yeah well we played a little bit of the
stand-up special uh as the cold open for
the show and I'm sure most of my
audience knows you from from YouTube and
and Rumble and elsewhere
um are you surprised that so many Comics
went woke I mean there are a ton of guys
I talk about on the show all the time
who I used to love and admire who were
my comic influences some of them my
friends who then just went off the deep
end with this woke politically correct I
mean that's the that's the danger really
not just woke but politically correct
and language freezing stuff that has led
us to all this
um I to be honest with you I have been
surprised that so many comedians have
gone woke because you I think of a
comedian as sort of the the rebel
against the system the system of
corruption I think the most important
thing about comedy is the truth
principle so at its core I consider
comedians to be people who represent
truth and they do it in a fun way and
it'll be goofy and insane along the way
so you know as you see a lot of people
in the country go woke I would have
expected a lesser percentage of
comedians to do that
um I can understand why they might I
mean I I think if someone outsources
their power and success to other people
whether it's a you know the Audience
Network or trying to get picked up by
some kind of agency I can see that's my
only hypothesis why someone would
abandon the truth principle and and
cater to political correctness when
they're comedians so I'm not totally
sure but that's my hypothesis on why
some haven't by the way you know and and
the ones who haven't meant they're like
it's a great time for business for
comedians who
just want to represent the truth no
matter who's speaking the hypocrisies
and you know I watch Ryan long Tyler
Fisher these guys who just
Shoot Straight arrows and and it's great
and and I think it's I love seeing a lot
of people discover them because there's
not a lot of competition for unwoke
comedians Jim Brewer is certainly in
that category he's been huge for forever
though
I opened for Jim Brewer at Caroline's in
New York City probably
2002. no kidding another lifetime ago he
was taking bong hits in the green room
before the show and he hands me the bong
and I'm like I dude this is like my it
was like my first like big break or
something I was like I am not taking a
bong hit before I walk out and he
crushed it the guy was baked out of his
mind he absolutely crushed it
hilarious
um so okay so the title of the special
is please censor this and I thought that
that was particularly apropos because
you launched on locals which obviously
everyone knows I started locals as a as
a a wall in essence against big Tech
censorship
um did you think about releasing you
know exclusively on YouTube or just
there's a Litany of places where you
could have done it but you did it with
us so I'm pretty happy about that yeah
you know I I thought about all the
possibilities and to be honest with you
Dave for a while I thought it was
defeated you know I there was a lot of
adversity to bring this special to the
world and the times of censorship we
live in and I'll I remember the my one
of my best friends on the planet he
directed this special his name's Brent
Pella he and I were in San Diego doing
shows for a weekend uh late last year
and I said bro I don't I I'm ready to do
a special I want to I don't think I can
obviously the the typical places Netflix
is in Amazon's given the nature of the
content I'm doing on stage they're not
going to have it it's just way removed
from the mainstream narrative I couldn't
even release it on YouTube for free if I
wanted to that would get my channel
deleted like that
and then uh my friend is like a wise
Sage he said JP do you know how much of
an idiot you are I said kinda but tell
me more and and he said you don't need a
distributor like you you've got a six
million person audience quit thinking in
the old Paradigm you are the distributor
so that really helped me open my eyes
and then uh along the way the idea of
like well let's reach out to locals and
Rumble see if we can do some kind of
partnership to just get this thing out
to the world and that value alignment
about what I stand for what the comedy
and the special represents and what
locals represents it's just that that
was perfect value alignment and it's
just been such a joy to get this special
out to the world I think in a beautiful
way you know if I did it completely
independently you know had some sort of
weird servers in my garage is special
and I'm screwing stuff up I I would have
been proud to do that but it's just
great to get it out within a very
established beautiful platform that that
actually brings the community together I
I love that aspect that's been such a
great bonus oh well I'm thrilled to hear
that I mean and that's exactly what it's
all about we we want people that have
audiences whether they're comedians or
actors or politicians or shoe salesmen
we want them to be able to reach their
people and we just give you the tools to
do it and then and then you go from
there are you like completely out of
whatever would be considered the LA
comedy world you know I've I've cut ties
with CAA I have nothing to do with it
anymore are you like just completely out
of that world altogether
yeah I I would say I'm very much removed
from the Hollywood world in the sense of
I have nothing on my bucket list that
involves Hollywood whatsoever
occasionally I'll I'll get people
reaching out they're doing an
independent film and like me to consider
a part in that and it and I'm willing to
consider it because it's independent
there's not some
big woke
china-backed BS ESG uh entity behind it
so I'm I love creativity and I love what
I stand for so when there's value
alignment I'm willing to consider oh an
independent film things like that but
the beautiful thing is life is so great
you know I get so much fulfillment
connecting with people releasing weekly
videos doing my stand-up having my
family so there's nothing else that I
need and man I'll tell you it's so great
to be completely unenslaved to the
Hollywood system and those kind of
powerhouses where you see what happens
what people do to themselves to
stay in line
they abandon their principles and that's
no way to live no and then and then
you've got we've done a bunch on them
lately you've got guys like Jimmy Kimmel
who used to be Politically Incorrect and
you know doing all of that stuff Carl
Malone and blackface Etc and now he's
the most woke politically correct person
there is it's it's a real flip on things
isn't mind-boggling in you know you
mentioned Jimmy Kimmel Howard Stern I
mean these people that's the one they
gained admiration because of their balls
and wittiness for standing up against
the establishment not like stand up
against establishment just to do it but
like corruption and the establishment
taking advantage of people that kind of
thing but now you see these guys they're
like oh
dude these checks are pretty large uh
maybe we'll become the establishment
it's just a weird mutation to see in
front of our eyes and you see it with so
many of them I mean Sarah Silverman's
another one like these people who were
they were edgy like they went for it's
not just like oh I was kind of like out
there a little I'm talking like The
Fringe case edgy comedians who then
became the most politically correct it's
I could do all day on that do you ever
long for the old days of Comedy like if
you were to open up my uh my YouTube on
my TV I'm watching old Johnny Carson I'm
watching all the all the legends of
years long gone by but the idea that you
could do stand up for a couple years you
get that five minutes you sit down with
Carson you get the sick I'm like there
was something really nice to the machine
as beautiful as all this freedom is
where in our day it's like there is
nobody to go to there's nobody's that I
I don't care to be on Kim ohler or
Colbert or or anything else which is
exactly what you're saying yeah but
there was a magic to it in a way yeah
you know there's the Nostalgia that that
was the olden days and then I was never
a professional comedian during that time
so it's just all looking back and and I
think it's a cool time to reminisce
about but there's no part of me that
wishes it was that day you know outside
of like the cool moments like if you got
to sit down with Carson like dude of
course like that's amazing but there was
so much outsourced power then like yeah
people couldn't take control of Their
Own Destiny and I think
self-responsibility is the greatest
superpower people have I think it's the
most UN underutilized power in our
country people are waking it up waking
up to it luckily but I love the idea of
like now
you take Destiny in your own hands if
you work hard you're consistent you put
stuff out online
if you're consistent with it and you
have some level of DNA to actually do
comedy you will build an audience
you will whether it's big small fast
slow that's you know that's a variable
but nobody needs to wait around being
discovered by the the industry anymore
so I just love the empowerment aspect of
how it is today
censorship
uh dragon in that but for aside from
that we we have a lot of power in our
hands and I love it yeah and it's on you
and it's like if you work harder and you
get better at your craft some good
things will probably happen not always
but I'd rather it be on me than than on
an agent or or on a Machinery that that
I can't control let me let's let's jump
off comedy for just a sec because you
are in Texas but you are in the Austin
area of Texas the weird area and when I
talk to other people from Texas let's
say my friends at the blaze over in
Dallas they often wonder what the high
hell is going on in Austin so what is it
like to be in a sort of blueish area in
a state that hopefully is about to go
even redder we'll see what happens over
the next couple days yeah well Rudder
the better in my opinion and that's not
just my Ginger lives matter politics
talking Day by the way the hair matching
the flag behind you really thank you I'm
grateful I was born in America it sucked
to be born in Ukraine with incompatible
flight colors
um I love Austin Austin has some of the
the best people who are Purpose Driven
Soulful and really going after their
dreams and contributing to a a better
world now there's certainly some leftist
stuff about how the City of Austin has
run that I don't agree with and you
certainly get some you know plenty of uh
eyes glazed over masturbation
psychosis addicts but you know I I
actually kind of like that Dave because
nobody I I think maybe we all want to
live in an echo chamber but one of the
worst things for us would be to just
live in an echo chamber so I true
diversity in my opinion is having a
diversity of perspectives and I like
that
but at the same time because Austin is
in Texas there's plenty of like-minded
people you know I've talked to people
all over the country and one of the
biggest pains that folks report is I
feel like I'm the only one I'm living in
San Francisco Portland so there's a lot
of community here and a few months ago
we we moved to a ranch about an hour
outside of Austin so now it's I mean
we're in Real Texas country now so it's
just you know if someone drives by we're
just in uh downtown a town where we live
uh in a coffee shop and someone drove by
with a vote for Beto bumper sticker and
it's just so cool how like dude that's
shocking we saw that out here that
someone driving by with a big Trump
bumper sticker in downtown Portland
it's funny because you know I'm I'm here
in Florida which is obviously you know
it's DeSantis country the Santa stand
depending on who you talk to and there's
one guy in my neighborhood with the
Charlie Chris sign and it's like it
actually of course it kind of seems
funny to me but I keep thinking one day
I'm going to be walking my dog and I
want to meet this person because what
could possibly be going on in their head
to live in the freest place and not want
that freedom however I respect their uh
desire of course to vote however they
wish
yeah man I
I like to understand what like cool why
one of my best friends we were sitting
around election night about two years
ago and we're just talking like hey
here's who I voted for and uh just one
person out of the group said yeah I
voted for Biden and it was so cool to
just
want to understand him and it was a
beautiful connective conversation and we
didn't agree but that didn't mean we had
to divide or not like each other it's it
was very interesting to learn oh that's
why you voted for Bible by the way talk
to him now and he's like dude I regret
it
uh him along with apparently 81 million
other people I think uh a lot of the I
don't know if all 81 but you know you
know
um in terms of doing
comedy for let's say a more conservative
or libertarian-minded crowd do you find
that there are rails that you can't
touch on that side that maybe you wish
you could touch but you can't quite get
to because of maybe more religious
issues that kind of thing you know
um I'm sure there's rails but I haven't
hit them yet
um you know just just recently I I've
really noticed especially in my stand-up
I'm Shifting the material you know
really so special and got now generate a
lot of new material and I'm Shifting the
material from doing sometimes bashing
the left as a butt of jokes to now it's
much more self-deprecating of a
conservative libertarian minded person
which is great I mean I love to honor
what I love by making fun of it and also
it's like if you can't laugh at yourself
you've got problems
so as I'm doing that I haven't found the
rails yet though in the past I can say
when before I got into politics I'm
doing stand-up and I would do some level
of Jesus kind of joke there you can tell
like all right there's there's some
folks who that was a a hot button for
them and maybe it came across
disrespectfully maybe it was just a good
joke and they didn't like it I don't
know but the past experiences I think
the religious piece probably is the
biggest
challenge when it comes to the
conservative crowd to you know dance
well with as opposed to just offend
yeah it's super interesting because
obviously my my credentials and
biography are not fully in line with say
what a conservative audience would be
showing up to and yet I get nothing but
love from these people and even when I
even when I get close to whatever that
line might be or say something that
makes them a little bit uncomfortable
that they haven't thought about before
it's like it's all good there really is
a sense of like it's all good yeah we
get that we can all be a little bit
different and it's okay yeah and I'm I
would guess with people who who watch
you see you and and sing with me they're
watching us because they already know us
they they love us they appreciate us so
there's already a big Rapport built out
of the countless videos of yours they've
seen so there's that trust as opposed to
just a comedian fresh off the street
going into the showroom the audience
doesn't know who they are less trust so
they they can probably get away with
less because they just don't know
exactly where that person's heart is but
they know where your heart is they know
where my heart is how many years did you
spend grinding through the clubs I I did
it for a long time man a long I started
in May of 98 right after college a week
after graduating college and I was doing
stand-up for men for at least a decade
like six nights a week and then the last
couple years before I left New York then
I was a little bit less started getting
into podcasting I saw the frontier the
New Frontier developing eventually moved
out to LA now back here but how many
years were you like in the grind of you
know you're one of ten on the show They
Don't Know Who You Are by the time you
get going you got to get off stage Etc
zero yeah
wow I admire that I took I so don't
recommend but here's the route I took
you know I I got known on on YouTube and
Just online videos first so the audience
was built up and then I got into stand
up and and I had already sort of been
doing a bit of stand up before I knew it
because once I started getting known
different conferences would come in hire
me to come in and speak and they're like
ah why don't you do some comedy I'm like
well cool that makes sense so I was
practicing it for a while without having
it in the frame of my mind to stand up
and and so as I was starting to stand up
I already had an audience and here's
what I don't recommend
I just jumped into the deep end because
I didn't know any better it's like all
right let's start headlining shows now
and I'm doing five shows in this city
rather than just starting slow so it was
very stressful and also like looking
back at my beginning stand up I'd say
like
I'm pretty embarrassed about it I mean
everybody is of their old stuff that's
how it is that's how it is of course so
it was good enough to give people a a
value and they they had love it was
great but the stand-up sucked so it
luckily though it was probably just
barely good enough that it wasn't a
complete train wreck because jumping
into the deep end starting the headline
pretty much right away it's not the
recommended course of action if that
gets derailed it's sort of like well
uh project failed uh so I I had a bit of
a unique route which again I don't
recommend and honestly I didn't even
I didn't know how normal
comedians like started like I wasn't
listening to Joe Rogan's podcast how he
talks about it I was just ignorance is
bliss and here's the way it suggested to
be by some team members and I was like
all right let's do that
you know it's so funny how everyone's
story is a little bit different because
so when I started uh Carson had retired
already so Leno took over but Leno
wasn't putting comics on the way Carson
was and I saw all of these guys that I
was coming up with that all wanted to
get on The Tonight Show and I was like
but he's not really putting anybody on
The Tonight Show he's not making Stars
the way Carson is and then because of
that after a couple years I heard about
this thing called a podcast I didn't
even know what it was I kid you not did
not know how to download I didn't even
know what it was that was on the phone I
wasn't even sure but I had a guy who
knew something about audio and I started
doing a little podcast early on and I
think I just followed that path so
everyone either you become the YouTube
Star first and then you figure it out
after or you just do it any any which
way I guess that gets to your freedom
point of doing something for yourself
yeah you know it's with great Freedom
comes great responsibility and it's
liberating and it's also scary you know
the the scary part is there's no
definitive structure that you need to
walk on so there's less security there's
less predictability there's probably a
fair bit more
having to figure it out and therefore
probably make a lot of errors and
mistakes what what year did you start
the podcast started in 98 98 May or 98.
you were doing a podcast in 98. oh no no
no it started stand-up sorry stand up
may of 98 and then I started the podcast
my first first podcast probably
2006 something like that like this was
still unbelievable I I didn't have the
internet at home in 2006. and you're
doing a podcast it was why I truly I had
a microphone this this big machine on
the desk I don't know what the hell I
was doing and then suddenly I was
getting emails and people were like I'm
listening to it I did not even know how
to put it on my own phone I I kid you
not what do you make about uh so
obviously this are we posted this before
or after the election I'm talking to my
guys while we're
this is either going up before or after
this coming election but we're taping it
before in full transparency okay so I'm
just told we're posting this after but
we're taping this before the election
what do you make of the general
temperature of the country right now
I'm shocked that it doesn't seem more
inflamed it that's interesting and and
that's not to say there's complete Peace
by any stretch but I just think back to
the the time before in the before the
2020 election and then that space
between the election and the
inauguration
good Lord that was a tense time now I
know this is not a presidential election
so that's part of it but when you look
at all the polling and it's like all
right we something weird really has to
happen for there not to be a huge Red
Wave
I'm surprised there's not more BS
happening I mean we see the the media
smearing manipulation like uh uh Donald
Trump did that to Paul Pelosi he's the
one yeah yeah they they knew immediately
it was a Maga person somehow they know
the nudists the BLM nudist that shows up
at the house yeah big Maga person so I
I'm I'm pleased with how peaceful things
have been
I'm pleased that more than any other
election that I can think of people seem
to care they seem to be ready to get out
to vote whichever way they want to vote
uh they they know we're we're living in
a time and place this the state of
things this is not sustainable they know
things need to change so I love seeing
the motivation happening as well and uh
then you know looking at the different
races there's hilarious stuff going on
like cool the fetterman debate like I
thought Biden was fun to watch like
he's got nothing on fetterman that's a
joke
so yeah I I think it's a cool time and I
I hope things are straightforward honest
with results and
uh yeah I I have hoped that we'll have
continued relative peace rather than
escalated inflammation but what one
thing I will say if I wanted to be
pessimistic is I would be worried about
what the media will do you know if
things don't go their way and it's
looking like it's not going to go the
way the mainstream media tries to sway
things you just never know what they'll
do to try to manipulate people who are
no longer being manipulated by them I
mean what kind of fear-mongering smears
lies I mean we've seen it all so how
much worse could it get I don't know but
maybe worse so yeah well it's
interesting because you know before you
were you were saying how you know comedy
it's so connected to truth or it should
be so connected to truth and it's like
man the media I always say it's like you
guys don't have to be great but just
don't be completely horrible but they
seem unable I mean almost completely
without exception there's a couple
exceptions
um unable to to stop themselves and stop
the lying and they're like they're just
so in on it they're in on they're in on
the big lie so to speak they are aren't
they and and I think given given their
jobs now we know The Narrative of what
their job is journalists uh that's not
the reality their jobs are giving
polarized opinions and we know the
polarized opinions are always
heavily leaning left so
you know a a golden retriever wants to
retrieve period
and the media wants to propagandize
that's what they do so you know I
honestly I pray for those people I I
certainly because we're all good people
at heart I think their behavior isn't
but I pray for those people that they
connect to a greater sense of purpose
that get I mean one of the greatest
gifts we can have is the Fulfillment we
get by contributing to the betterment of
another person or people now they do the
opposite of that
but I just prayed for them that they
they make some choices that allow
themselves to get fulfilled like Kerry
Lake's story is so inspiring for me she
was so successful in the media but she
couldn't she just couldn't take the idea
of lies lies lies she couldn't take the
feeling of unfulfillment so
she made a different choice and now
she's really doing a great job of
working on contributing to the
betterment of
a lot of people yeah it's interesting I
mean we we talk about on the show a lot
it's like we can all focus on politics
all the time but this isn't exactly a
political problem it's a spiritual
problem or a personal problem and if we
can solve that at the ground level then
maybe we can solve the rest of it yeah I
think we need uh I think before any
politician goes into office they need to
do some deep inner child work
she can quit compensating for how
unloved you felt as a kid or abuse you
might have went through if you can quit
compensating for that you're probably
going to be doing a lot better job be a
lot less corrupt a lot less control and
power hungry and more service oriented
so it's funny that you know even hearing
you say that it you know obviously I I'm
here in Florida I love DeSantis but it's
not I always say it's not because of
like that I worship politicians it's
like he's a guy who happened to step
into this thing and then has fought for
our freedoms he's not out there like you
owe me this this is the power I want
over you I think whether he knew it or
not he did some of that that child work
yeah inner child stuff you know I
wouldn't be surprised and and DeSantis
served in the military so he's he's got
perspective of what really matters I I
don't know his exact military field
experiences but he's probably had things
put in perspective and I think when
people have things put into perspective
you know for me having my son was a big
piece of that you realize how much power
and control just don't matter there's
such a worthless currency compared to
the currency of connection
contribution
Joy I mean hell even laughter for that
matter
so some of my favorite politicians are
the ones that don't want to be
politicians
they're called to do it in order to
serve
JP I give you my word that locals will
never censor you that's that's number
one uh number two we're gonna link to
the special right down below and uh this
will either go down as a great interview
or a completely Haywire interview
depending on what happens during the
election since we're taping it before
and releasing it after but we ain't
editing it either way so we'll see what
happens we should do two versions where
we make predictions so we can look at
like psychics
JP Sears thank you my friend good to see
you
great to see you Dave thank you for
having me
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell